eric lauer second consecutive start
coming off the coveted list rock and
seeing somebody new for the first time
in a month you can see what he's been
able to do at home last four home starts
outstanding work a 123 earned run
average had a good fast ball good change
up
thomas overall 161 including his time
with st louis
he's driving the ball the other way
again this one's got some altitude it's
it's gonna bounce over the wall in right
center
and lane thomas is now five for nine
as annette
i remember what happened the last time
he batted with two men aboard in the
first inning
three-run homer the other way wednesday
afternoon right here at nationals park
with a homer two rbis and two walks
up the middle base hit
thomas can fly he's around third scoring
easily and over to third goes escobar
and the line is moving right out of the
dugout
in milwaukee the nats are on top and
juan soto rbi number 67.
ryan zou for two against lower career 31
rbis as a starter this year with nine
home runs
zimmerman's going to elevate deep left
center
and casually taken by bradley
holmes escobar
back to first is soto
bradley might have fooled soto into
thinking he wasn't going to catch it or
else juan might have been tagging but
the gnats lead to nothing
and a wheel back towards second not in
time
soto just able to get that hand
under the tang of urias
looks like the brewers are going to take
another look and i think that's a really
good challenge you're trying to find a
way to get eric lauer out of this inning
that's a great way to do it no kidding
there it is right here is the hand on
the back
i don't think so i don't think so either
he's out
headsets coming off
we got it out good challenge by the
brewers and their video replay room
two two
fly ball left field
back yelledge looks like he's got a play
on the warning track
challenge well received
so pablo espino first start against
milwaukee has his work cut out for him
against the southpaw swingers
last start august 15th against the
braves took the six to five loss gave up
five runs on eight hits over four
innings of work christian yelich did not
start
the opener last night against the
left-hander patrick corbin
and he drives this one towards right
center
drifting back still back and it is gone
yelich
his first home run here at american
family field in almost two months
they need him to get hot get hot stay
hot the rest of the year
fastball upper 80s up in the zone number
seven of the year
for christian yell it's our powerball
home run account and the 01 delivery is
hit in the air to center and deep jackie
bradley way back and he'll make the
catch at the wall
[Applause]
alcitus escobar hit by a pitch and a
strikeout victim today
fastball up escobar lines it to left
will keep an eye on thomas he's
approaching third he's flying home
he will score easily
and the nats have a two-run lead again
escobar first hit of the day
starting to work a little bit more here
for
jake cousins and right now he's got
zimmerman that great slider that cousins
has
chopper
go to second one onto first
pick not in time nice pick by rowdy
teles that ball gets by him escobar
is going to be able to score the catch
swinging a bullet to a grab by reyes and
a backhanded flip
to colton wong covering at second base
to end the inning
janice is in there runners at the
corners only one out one-o coming
swinging a bouncer right field base hit
runs gonna score
wong's gonna go from first to third
brewers are within a run
yelich having himself an afternoon
starting to feel it isn't he
and that one's popped up right side
foul ground zimmerman makes the catch
tagging trying to score long
safe at home he just tagged up on a
pop-up and fog round and nobody ever
coming home playing how about that heads
up base running by colton long 3-3 game
check it out keep on just kind of
watching what's going on he's got to
cover home plate
or somebody does
forgot all about colton wong
the nationals are going to review what
awareness from colton wong as he
realized nobody was going to cover home
plate he went over to tag
and here he comes
did zimmerman ever get him
that is one heck of a play i've never
seen that before
never in my life have i seen that before
and a foul pop
about 20 feet from home plate
there it is you'll see it here see where
the contact is
looks like the toe is on the plate
before the tag zimmerman never touches
him before he gets that back foot the
left foot
he doesn't get the front foot he's safe
and he is safe
wow what a play from colton wong that's
the base running play of the year right
there folks
off the foot of promise it's in the
center
yelling is going to score and just like
that the brewers have the lead
would take it
tries to knock it down with his foot
reed directs it away from escobar and
into center field
standing right there waiting for that
ground ball
that'd be a base hit
one ball and no strikes on
yadiel hernandez
gaddiel hernandez launches one to left
[Applause]
c
you
later
well that'll quiet down a
30 000 or so
yadiel with his sixth of the year he
takes the lefty out the other way
and then answer back even
and now back-to-back singles by soto and
zimmerman with one out
and here's carter kibu
and he struck him out
fastball right on the outside corner
1-2
fly ball center field jackie bradley jr
looks like he's got a beat on it on the
warning track and the inning is over
and the brewers have loaded the bases
here in the bottom of the seven and i
bet you're going to hear some rowdy
chants
look like you threw him a slider got a
pop-up
key boom grabs it looked like a fair
ball and that is
over
now the top of the order in colton wong
still loaded
one out in field up
and he got hit
the birds are going to take the lead on
another hit by pitch
all right here's yellows
bases loaded 5-4 brewers
another 3-2 pitch to yelich
hammered
deep right
he just hit one with the bases loaded
his second home run in the game
and ripped it out of here in right
center and no doubt about that one
gets a curtain call here from the folks
in his home ballpark
the 2-2
struck him out swinging it's over
finally
9-6
another come-from-behind victory for the
brewers christian yelich
blasts two homers
drives in six and hader
finally puts the finishing touches on
the nationals
you